people are always so split when it comes
to Cinderella
some say it's a charming fairytale
others say it's an incredibly sexist
story I guess I'm somewhere in between I
mean yeah de Cinderella really have to
stay with that family could she have
left at a time
probably but if the story is done right
you focus on the things that are the
most important like how being hopeful
patient loving and a hard worker can
finally pay off this is the idea they
were trying to do with the new
Cinderella that in my opinion doesn't
really come across the story still seems
basically on track Cinderella's a young
girl who has a father that she loves
very much but he tragically passes away
leaving her with her stepmother and
stepsisters the three of them don't like
Cinderella and immediately start to
treat her like a slave trying to be
optimistic she obeys all their commands
hoping one day to accept their love but
she slowly starting to realize it's
never gonna happen
she bumps into a young man who happens
to be a prince and they start to hit it
off until they find out their situation
and realize that they're probably never
gonna be anything more than friends if
even that but the father wants the
Prince to marry and so they hold a great
big ball for him to socialize the
stepmother and stepsister don't let her
go to the ball but of course a fairy
godmother comes and shows her the way
through kindness and magic she
transforms a pumpkin into a carriage and
her rags into a beautiful dress her
shoes in the glass slippers and she's
off to the ball she once again hits it
off with the prince but she needs to
leave resulting in one of her slippers
being left behind and thus the maiden
who can fit the slipper will marry the
prince
sounds pretty standard to the
traditional Disney formula but there are
a few changes some good some bad let's
talk about the good stuff seeing how -
Kenneth Branagh film once again it looks
amazing the colours the sets the
Scimitar Effie it's like you're really
in a fairy tale there's a lot more
detail given two characters that didn't
get much attention in the original that
sorely needed it for example the prince
is much more fleshed out yeah he isn't
just a bit of hunk arm candy he's
actually a very interesting character as
is the king and even the stepmother has
a little bit more development as we
actually see her and the husband try to
get along try to have a little bit of a
life together but realise that they're
not quite
and for one another so you see the seeds
of how she would become so despicable
it's also kind of interesting seeing the
development of Cinderella starting off
as the stepdaughter then slowly becoming
the may they don't just immediately say
go to the kitchen they say Oh would you
like to help out wouldn't you like to
make things easier leading to a point
where they don't even let her sit at the
same table anymore which is the scene
where she finally breaks down it's
emotionally effective you really feel
bad that she will never be a part of
this family I also kind of liked the
idea that the fairy godmother is
disguised as a peasant but then when
Cinderella treats her with kindness
that's when she gives her the reward a
good lesson but isn't the idea that
she's being rewarded for kindness all
through her life it's kind of weird that
she something gets all this stuff just
for treating one person in a good way
but whatever you get the idea
honestly the film in many respects does
do a lot of good updates that is except
for one element that is kind of an
important element and that's Cinderella
herself if you watch the interviews they
all talk about how she's not a damsel in
distress and she's not a waif and I
really hate it when they do that because
it's like okay we know what she's not
what is she then the answer is not very
interesting ironically in trying to make
the character more strong and
independent they actually make her more
submissive and more dependent in the
original cartoon her father dies when
she's a child so it makes sense that she
would be used to this way of living that
she's supposed to be the servant here he
dies when she's practically an adult so
it doesn't make any sense why she
wouldn't just leave in fact there's a
scene where friends are asking her why
don't you just leave and she's like oh
it's my father's place I would feel bad
that makes no sense and she ends up
leaving at the end anyway so it makes
doubly no sense and when it does show
her childhood it's some of the worst
stuff in the movie it actually starts
off showing how over-the-top Pleasant
her life is and it is painful it is
beyond sappy it's like it's made for
three-year-olds which if the movie was
made for three-year-olds fine but it's
clearly not it supposed to be made for
everybody it's supposed to make adults
feel like children and children like
adults just know if you're watching it
the first couple minutes is not a
reflection of the rest of the film and
following that over-the-top happy
childhood she herself is also
over-the-top happy there's one scene
where she finally breaks down it's a
very welcomed scene but all the other
times she just kind of smiles and
Pleasant and I'm sorry that's not
interesting I know a lot of people
remember the original Cinderella as
being just very bland and not very
interesting but you know what
she had her limits she could get angry
she could get frustrated you could see
in the animation the performance that
she's constantly telling herself just
get through it just get through it
so when it leads to the scene where the
dress is ripped apart and she has
nothing left it's genuinely
heartbreaking in this movie when they
rip the dress apart it doesn't mean a
thing
yeah she cries and she feels sad but it
feels like we're going through this
simply because it's the Cinderella story
we kind of got to go through it it
didn't feel burned we already had the
big cry scene when she realizes she is
in part of the family and it was very
effective but because of that you're
taking away from a moment that should
have been huge because you did it a
little too early on top of that there's
a scene at the end where she's locked in
the Attic now in the original she tries
to get out she's banging on the door
she's calling for help
in this one she's just so happy thinking
about her prince and also somehow so sad
that she thinks nobody would want to see
her that she does nothing she just spins
around singing to herself oh my god this
is supposed to be the stronger more
independent version a good strong
character is supposed to work with their
flaws you're supposed to see what their
problems are and see them work through
it
the original Cinderella is trying to
work through a mindset that she's had
since childhood and see that she is
worth the effort she's worth breaking
out she's worth going behind her
stepmother than stepsisters back here
much more than the original she waits
for someone to come and save her
in the original she's at least making an
attempt to get out I'm sorry these are
big problems with this character so does
I make it a bad movie oh kinda I mean it
is called Cinderella so you would think
Cinderella should be good and
interesting but it's kind of hard seeing
how they update all these other elements
the prince is more interesting the King
is more interesting the stepmother is
interesting there's less of cute little
mice and more chemistry between the
romantic leads somewhere between this
live-action version and the anime
version there's a really good rendition
of Cinderella that's waiting to get out
honestly if you want a good one that
actually has an interesting character
and tells the story in a unique
some way go see ever after in my opinion
is the most fun and interesting
rendition of the Cinderella story with a
smart interesting complex lead with this
one it is difficult to like if you don't
make your main character relatable where
the original did have problems that were
just kind of problems of Disney fairy
tales in the day this one updates some
but then makes others a little worse I
guess I'm glad I saw it I mean it did
look interesting and it was very elegant
and pretty it obviously tried really
hard it just tried so hard in some areas
that it got lost and confused about what
it actually was getting across it's hard
to say if you're looking for just a nice
little fairy tale where women wear
pretty dresses and dance with princes
and such you'll like it fine if you want
to feel more emotion than you did the
original Cinderella I don't know if
you're gonna get much of that because
like I said it's just hard to relate
with this character I guess it's just
kind of a pick your poison
grab a pumpkin and see for yourself
you